what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today i am going
to be reacting to a video by
steph is cold labeled red pill all women
cheat before i start do not forget to
subscribe to the channel and ring that
notification
bell that way you're going to be
notified of my daily videos
okay so this is interesting to me
because
i have never cheated on anybody so
we'll see what this guy's got to say
what up y'all it's steph
you are now tuned with dom game division
let's get it
[Music]
all right his intro music fire
[ __ ] they all okay
[Music]
how the [ __ ] you read people you think
that women don't cheat
well the ones who don't cheat are the
ones with no
options [ __ ] they all got options
[ __ ] let me get to this guy light right
now
looking at [ __ ] they all got options
they all cheat because they can
because there's no consequences because
they can get away with it
because that you not gonna send those
screenshots to the husband
like abusing cheat on her the [ __ ] girl
senior screenshots to your wife
there is no consequences when she cheats
okay uh first of all
women and men cheat at practically the
same right
people cheat people do bad things if
given the opportunity to do bad things
most people
will do bad things that's why and even
in the bible it talks about like the
road to heaven as an arrow
people in general take the easy way out
um
i would agree um i could see like a side
chick getting more mad than like a side
guy um but i will say in 2021
i think it's a lot harder to get away
with cheating i think cheating is a lot
easier
to do these days but it's a lot harder
to get away with because
no matter what you do there's evidence
like even if you go to a hotel
with someone there's security footage if
you really want to go get it
he actually gets praised for it so you
think the [ __ ] won't cheat on you
are you delusional [ __ ] i don't know
who praises
okay are you [ __ ] delusional
[ __ ] they all cheat
they all cheat
i was still hanging i was on bga's
handguard last night just listening
and some tony she probably watching this
[ __ ]
i had the nerve to say she had never
cheated on her husband
man let me tell you something fam
i used to think when i was blue pill i
used to say man i never cheated on my
wife and my wife and never
my girl that never do me like that [ __ ]
the nerve of you [ __ ] man
let me tell you something fam
let me tell you something bro nine times
out of ten
your woman you aren't her sexual
preference when you're in a relationship
with her that's just facts
so when you're not her sexual preference
what the [ __ ] does that mean
i can't hear you boys
um i have seen girls
change their type when they end up
getting married or whatever so i could i
could possibly see that
um i wouldn't say nine times out of ten
i would say like 50 50. oh
that's why
that's facts
that's facts
nine times out of ten fam you married to
a chick you're not that you're not her
sexual best
and when you marry the game really over
you
when you marry your chick you just
handed her the keys you hadn't heard a
sword kill me i'm dead
just as bad as we want to see your fat
ass and like damn
[ __ ] this [ __ ] out that [ __ ] you think
that when they see that dude and be like
damn i suck his dick
or damn i bounce on his dick you think
they don't be like that
you think they don't think like that
girls don't think like that i mean i
don't want to say girls in general
but when a girl is attracted to a guy
it's not generally in a sexual way
at first i think girls are a lot more
attracted to like a guy's charisma and
personality before like the physical
you think that these women ain't gonna
cheat on you because they love you
[Laughter]
because she said she cared for you and
y'all got kids
but she giving you chore sex and you
think she won't cheat on you
you're not pulling that [ __ ]
a six has more options than me
because [ __ ] are so thirsty a [ __ ] on
my smv level will [ __ ] a six
because he's desperate because he's
going through a drop you think she won't
[ __ ] a [ __ ] like me
if she is six is she married
i would have given him a sex
i [ __ ] wife dog
oh my husband did can't get hard
you know he just don't [ __ ] me right but
i know you can you think they not all
like that
[Music]
in that situation you think they are not
like that then i asked the lady
you ever realize people project like the
way they view themselves onto the world
like genuinely so if you view the world
a certain way
it's through the lens that you looked at
the world through so like
if you're a cheater you're gonna see
that everyone else is a cheater
guarantee he does that stuff that's why
he looks at the world this way
i'm not saying people don't cheat in
general i don't really have a
super positive view of humanity i think
given
in the right circumstances a lot of
people would do things they say they
wouldn't do
but in situations like that i think it's
about not putting yourself
in those situations i said
so if your husband can provide uh this
lavish lifestyle for you
but he can't make you come you know he
don't sexually turn you on would you
cheat on him
this [ __ ] said no the nervous [ __ ]
the [ __ ] lion
that [ __ ] is lying through her teeth
dude if your woman is above a seven
[ __ ] that [ __ ] are so thirsty these
days
y'all [ __ ] above a six she getting at
least
10 dms a day 10 approaches a day five
snapchat requests a day don't let her
post a thirsty picture
don't let it be a dumb like me and that
[ __ ]
you think she ain't gonna bounce on this
dick and she ain't bouncing on yours
you think she ain't going to suck a
bigger dick than yours
or her sexual preference what if her
sexual preface is little dicks
what if our sexual prefaces are short i
feel so uncomfortable this is weird
dude you a tall dude you didn't want to
[ __ ] that shark [ __ ]
just because she love you [ __ ] love
ain't real
and love ain't got [ __ ] to do with
cheating because love don't make her
[ __ ] wet
love is a feeling feelings change
and she never i don't think love is a
feeling i think love is a choice
you can choose to love someone or you
can choose to not like loving someone is
loving them
even when you don't want to loving them
loving someone is not cheating on them
even when you want to
and even if you do loving somebody is
doing the right thing and telling the
truth about it
and not lying to them like i don't know
love is
the older i get the more and more i
think it's a choice first day's the same
hey rt
they all get away with you think these
celebrities ain't cheating on their
husbands
why do you think these [ __ ] get caught
but the [ __ ] don't
i'm gonna tell you why one reason why a
[ __ ] get why [ __ ] get caught and why
[ __ ] don't get caught
because the [ __ ] can't stay a side
[ __ ] for the rest of her life
a [ __ ] is naturally envious of of the
next [ __ ]
a [ __ ] is naturally envious of the wife
or girlfriend
and she always wants to take her spot so
when she's [ __ ] you just know that
she's going to tell your wife or your
girlfriend
screenshots are a [ __ ] and she
will best believe
screenshots all messages and send it to
your wife or girlfriend you [ __ ]
you can never cheat in peace [ __ ]
thanks to gynocracy
gangster thanks to the gyno yeah that's
a real thing
yeah in society you could never [ __ ]
[ __ ] this piece you can never get your
dick sucking piece
[ __ ] you can't even beat your meeting
piece [ __ ] your wife banging down that
[ __ ] door
with her her
oh she can do whatever the [ __ ] she
wanted yeah that would make sense to me
because men
um don't attach through sex as much as
women that would make sense
she can go to the store around the
corner hey i'll be back
but again i think it's getting harder
and harder to cheat because you have a
digital trail
so even even let's say you go
somewhere like you don't go to a hotel
you go somewhere like there's like no
cameras whatever
you still have your phone
but that's a digital trail like there's
always a digital trail
even if you use snapchat i'm just like
thinking of ways like if you use
snapchat
location services if the dude like puts
on your location without you knowing
boom 20 minutes bouncing on the [ __ ]
dick come back
act like ain't [ __ ] happen especially if
you're a blue pill [ __ ] hey
honey
how's it going babe you're back already
yeah
yeah bouncing on that [ __ ] dig fast as
a [ __ ] coming everywhere
you don't know
yeah babe you came back so quick [ __ ]
goofy ass [ __ ] better wake the [ __ ] up
two the [ __ ] know you
the [ __ ] know you you gonna shake that
[ __ ] win
you gonna shake that [ __ ] hand and the
other day he [ __ ] your [ __ ]
and she know it
you [ __ ] cuck you [ __ ] blue pill
scent man johnny [ __ ] cup
wow you [ __ ] [ __ ] you let her get
away with that [ __ ]
who are you do you think this guy seems
like he would be very
paranoid in a relationship because
he literally looks at the world as every
woman cheats
you think the [ __ ] is gonna screenshot
their messages and send it to you
the nerd for you [ __ ] no
[ __ ] no that's why these [ __ ] don't
get caught
these [ __ ] don't get caught because
women cheat better women are more
sneakier
women get away [ __ ] cheating this [ __ ]
all you gotta do is slide on the
[ __ ] dm and tell them to meet
you somewhere
[ __ ] do the same thing [ __ ] do
[ __ ] do the same thing [ __ ] do the
only thing is
[ __ ] don't [ __ ] don't run their
mouth like [ __ ] do
that's it that's the only reason why
she don't get caught she don't get even
if she doesn't tell the girl she'll tell
you
she'll tell her friends [ __ ] [ __ ]
smarter
no the [ __ ] they don't [ __ ] shut the
[ __ ] up
[ __ ] she's smarter they think it out
think about what they got bouncing on
this dick
i think about [ __ ] a big booty [ __ ]
who gonna tell my wife that big booty
[ __ ]
who gonna tell her husband nobody gets
she can get it
okay um
that that was a fun video you know um
seems like some quality dating advice
i mean look at the end of the day people
cheat
people steal people lie people do things
so
i'm not surprised when he says women
cheat just as much
if not more than men that doesn't shock
me
but it's just a malicious like view on
the world because
there's good people but again what do
they say in the bible the road to heaven
is narrow
so there's probably more bad than gut if
i had to guess
but i don't know i really think that
through but anyways let me know in the
comments if you guys agree or you
disagree do not forget to
subscribe to the channel and bring that
notification bell i will talk to you
guys next time